a reason but it was also a lack of
self-control and discipline but there
was a reason for you right right right
but but the reason like the reason
behind the reason like why did I get to
that place in the first place
that's what I'm no no I'm saying before
before the reason I was in the point
where I was eating foods that weren't
nutrient dense was a lack of
self-control right okay I love ice cream
you know what I mean like I was and and
you know a lot of the foods that I was
eating were like microwavable Foods
right right so it was a lack of
self-control it's lazy I didn't want to
cook okay and and so but that was me
being lazy and taking accountability for
that gave me better results right and so
it's not kind to bail out women for
their bad decisions because it gives
them worse results
women I'm using the word that you used
in in that sense
do you feel like it has better results
as well because I don't feel like the
tough love to go back to the message
it's a short-term solution it's like a
plot it's like putting a plaster on you
need to expose the wound so that it can
I agree because the thing is do you have
a son or a daughter a son you have a son
okay so if he got really obese right
okay but let's say he's 15 is really
obese right yeah and he's obese because
of a justifiable reason in your eyes
okay yeah right you're just gonna let
him be obese are you going to try and no
but the thing is there's a reason
there's a reason okay but no no one's
saying there isn't a reason right all
we're saying is that you are in control
of your weight right and so anybody who
is big
it is down to the decision like they're
in control I'm not disputing that okay
so we agree then yeah no we this that's
the thing we agree but my thing is maybe
it's just it's maybe it's the language
we're using that I'm fine because I just
feel no I agree because I feel like it's
very cotton shut and that there's no
gray area in what I feel like you guys
are are saying concerning it it's very
much your big lose weight end of but I
think that's just not loud
you can't say that like that could that
could be the the surface level right
right but it can't be okay well you are
big there may be reasons behind it
justifiable reasons that when you
understand let's look into that then and
then that's where our solution will lie
no no no looking for the reason that's
not the solution that's not the solution
exactly one at a time please the
solution will be in the reason but the
idea right the idea of being fat I
understand it might not be black and
white right however you can you can look
for the reason it can be whatever
however the solution will always be you
probably need to eat less
right that's and that's what we said
that's what we're saying this is what
this is what I think we agree because
that's all I said if you if you're not
eating you will lose weight that's what
I said if that was what you said I
wouldn't but that was the whole point of
the that was the whole point of example
with countries with famine I just felt
like you weren't giving space for other
factors no you made it sound like you
are big one plus one is two you are big
lose weight if life was that black and
white we'd be yeah what was I think what
we're saying is the factors don't matter
in the sense of in the sense no what I
mean is the factors don't matter in
regards to what the solution is exactly
that's what we're saying I disagree then
I'm gonna disagree because the factors
are the reason why the the weight
problem was created in the first place
right and it's true the statement as to
you know the statement of your fat you
need to lose weight is a true it's a
good statement right and and the and the
the truth behind that is that you have
to find out why you got fat for example
with you you said you were lazy right
and even with you as you said with
hormonal not hormonal with emotional
eating and disorders right we've got to
look at what uh eating disorder really
is you're feeling some type of way
there's some sort of issues some
emotional issues anxiety whatever it is
probably caused from trauma or however
it's happened and instead of dealing
with it the person is choosing to fill
that void and kind of stimulate
themselves
did you hear that yeah it's a good
choice yeah so there's always a choice
there like you're feeling the emotions
but you have a choice to either address
their emotions or eat and stimulate
yourself and get fat well and all the
solutions are pretty much the same
though you eat healthy foods
eat less calories exercise that's my
point don't be comfortable in your own
skin but you know what's also or do
nothing and just stay fat no but like if
you don't find the cause then you don't
have the the emotional uh stimuli drive
as to why to to to solve it but you know
what's also a choice because some people
it's not over to eat right some people
over some people under eat it starts if
there's a blanket thing that people with
that specific element do they don't just
all overeat and so it is a choice of how
you choose to you know you decide to eat
your feet and decide to go to the gym
you start to play games in order to
wherever that trauma was it's still a
choice
you have to be at peace with the
decisions you make so what I mean by
that is if you overeat as an example and
you put on weight you have to be at
peace with the fact that you might not
be able to find that high attainable man
and you can't moan about that so you
just have to it's ownership and
accountability and I think that's where
the issue is there is accountability I
actually very much agree with because I
don't want people to think that I just
hate fat people or anything like that
I'm not no no what I'm saying is that
we're super fat people in a labor camp
so we get free work and they lose weight
what I'm actually saying is I I don't
want people to to think that that's what
I'm saying what I'm actually saying is
if you are fat your decisions led to
that that's all I'm saying and you can't
expect other you can't expect the water
give you understanding you just can't
unfortunately about the people that it
didn't lead to that I had a friend right
and I'm not gonna accept this out here
too tough but
um he had sort of a I think it was an
Autumn Auto autoimmune disease or we had
some sort of disorder
um some sort of disease and the
medication from that disease caused them
to put on an extreme amount of weight
what would you say to him
did it make him obese not obese okay
then exactly no I know people I know
people because and that's what we're
talking about there's not many people
like that sorry yeah so I was gonna say
I know people that have had like medical
issues um but yeah we're not talking
about those people and I think we just
have to have understanding for that
right we're talking about the Gen no but
that's the exception to the rule yeah
we're talking about like a couple of
thousand in millions and billions of
people I mean maybe I've exaggerated
there but we're talking about the masses
like the 90 you know the rest the rest
of civilization so only those people but
there's no there's no there's no
medication that makes you obese I never
said it was obese but it just made him
not I don't know retain water or
something but there's a difference
between putting on weight right and then
being overweight so so I'm just trying
to get it clear that the main issue is
that the the presence of choice that's
the main thing we're talking people you
can be obese if it was like I have a
reason no no no no no no the main the
main issue is that we don't hold women
accountable and we coddle them for poor
choices right that's that's the main
issue and do you know what's funny bro
like if this was any other context I
really wouldn't even disagree with you I
really wouldn't be having that internal
battle that I would be like yeah we do
we do we do even marketing you know how
certain products are marketed it's it's
to
Hodder women in a way on certain things
but I just feel like in this regard it's
just too I feel like if I didn't take
this stance no one would and it'll just
be too simple but the thing is that
people should should do so you're saying
that uh people are coddled what is the
solution I suppose what I would like to
see is to get rid of movements like body
positivity and start putting these women
on a pedestal for being fat that's what
I would like to see I'd like to see
women actually being honest with each
other and stop telling their fat friend
that nothing's wrong that's that's what
I would like to see I could see the
women are happy with themselves
they're all bodies out there for
everyone to see and say like oh like
that's how I look or even it body
positivity isn't just about size it's
also about so on Instagram for example I
mean it all still feels a little bit
fake but there are a lot more women who
are starting to post themselves in
angles and positions which aren't as
flattering and that as a woman is is
good to see because it's just a reminder
okay actually we don't all look perfect
every day like we I mean I think it's
just common sense like Instagram is for
models
they're not real it's still good to see
because those kinds of things are in
your face every single day Common Sense
isn't common I see Raw all the time on
Tick Tock and then and plus even
Victoria's Secret they're getting fat
chicks in there now fat chicks are
coming in I see I see more rolls thrown
in my face all the time I don't want to
see that I want to see the girl I can't
be so I can work out to be her okay
that's what I want to see I see [__] as
motivation
just because just because
yeah I think the problem the problem
really is that a lot of men have is when
women say that if you do not like fat
women you are fat phobic that idea
I'm not scared of fat people I just
don't find fat people I think it's I saw
this thing on Instagram that was like
it's selfish to be fat because everyone
has to look at you wow
because when you're overweight you put
everyone like when I get on an airplane
and someone's overweight next to me like
that's putting me but I have to deal
with your poor choices why do I have to
deal with that goes against the liberal
principle of uh you know I forgot what
it's good but you know your choice is
not affecting other people yeah yeah I
know what you mean and even and even if
you do get overweight then you're on the
health then you go to the hospital early
right and the taxpayers have to deal
with your poor decisions
it's not intolerable it's it's that it's
that yeah it's the number it's that
you're making other people deal with
your poor choices and if you wanna if
you want to be fat and I don't have to
deal with the consequences fine fine
that's totally fine go do you but my
issue is that they're putting their
insecurities on men and saying like me
like us look at us no no we don't want
models on the cover of Victoria's Secret
you have to look at us what the [__] we
don't want to look at you
and I wouldn't be I wouldn't be on I
wouldn't go up to Victoria's Secret and
say hey I think you should have six foot
gingers on the line why look at me look
at me I should be the beauty standard
like what if I went what if I went to
all the modeling agencies and said I
should be the beauty standard why don't
I see girls that look just like me no no
because
narcissistic narcissism
I disagree and the reason I disagree
because going back to what we were
saying about Khloe Kardashian right It's
All About the Benjamins right yes and I
think the stat was what 42 of people are
obese is what you were saying earlier
that's your target addressable market so
by definition they should be on the
cover because it's more sales more money
it's all about shareholders
but it's about it's about women that's
the you're right it's women putting
women above men and that's that's what
I'm saying because 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions are made by women and
so I'm glad you said that because at the
end of the day it's not for the men it's
for the women and even the body
positivity movement is for the women
it's always about women Pearl do you
have any Fat Friends
dudes
no no no I was like I don't really have
a lot of friends I talk to my family I
have 10 siblings so I don't know I just
hang out with them to be honest
I think a big reason why this is
happening all of this body positivity is
happening now in this sense is because I
don't think historically women have ever
been sexually rejected by men I don't
think they ever have but I think we live
in times now where because sex is given
so freely that to the top now they're uh
top percent men
that will discriminate against certain
women which before sexually never happen
because sex wasn't moving us through
yeah Genghis Khan was just nice I don't
think that's why it is I honestly think
it all centers around social media
because there was never the pressures of
social media before so now women are far
more insecure than they ever have been
that's true but no one's forcing you to
be on Instagram in fact no they're not
but but social media
yes yes please guess I think you're
gonna complain about this social media
that you choose
no like I I agree like social media has
massively impacted our culture and the
way we live in you know how people feel
about themselves
um but I I think there's a reason
there's a reason why a there's a reason
about it why body positivity is only for
women yes not for men and I don't see
women complaining about them it's not
it's not for men
because let me ask you why do you think
it's only for women what is body
positivity it's not for men why do you
think it's only why do you think it's
only encouraged for women not men
yeah that women are more and empowering
they were more emotional we're more
empathetic I think it was the way yeah
um so I think I think I think it boils
down to that and I do think men are a
lot tougher on themselves
why don't women support big men why do
we support big men y'all don't support
yourselves you said women are more
pathetic yeah right so why are they not
empathetic towards the larger men oh no
my answer even though I said it ingest
it's the truth if you are an empathetic
towards yourself but we're not we're not
talking about why not men I'm not
talking about I'm saying the reason lies
in there why should I feel like that's
probably why we're not so you're saying
because men are empathetic to big men
that's why we're not I feel like perhaps
the answer lies in there I'm not
entirely sure of course but I feel like
perhaps the answer lies in there
although I said earlier that I would
date a bigger man so no but I don't
think women are against male body
positivity but it's about women
understanding how it feels and trying to
like get together and build each other
up and say do you know what bikini body
is everybody like that's what the Yeah
when I was over with I wasn't wearing a
bikini I was like I don't deserve it
I'm sorry I got a question for the
ladies right if you're a beach right and
you see a fat man with his top off why
are you putting them like no because as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible